[Müzik]
arkeologların
arkeoloji bölgelerinde buldukları
yazıtlara baktığınızda eski tarihi
kayıtlara baktığımızda günümüzden
20-25.000 yıl önce insanlar Devlerin
kurduğu çadırların içerisinde
yaşadıklarını dünyanın sadece ve sadece
bundan ibaret olduğunu düşünüyorlardı
öylesine korkak öylesine cahillerdi ki o
çadırdan başlarını çıkartıp gökyüzüne
bakmaktan bile yetiyorlardı ve
kaza kafalarını kaldırıp gökyüzüne şöyle
baktıklarında gece gördükleri
yıldızların içinde yaşadıkları o çadır
gibi yapının kılacağı yerlerinde meydana
gelen delikler olduğunu dışarıda bir
şeylerin ışıldadığını o ışığın o çadırın
deliklerinden içeri girdiklerini ve
Orada gördüğün O beyaz beneklerin o
çadırın delikleri olup gökyüzünde yıldız
şeklinde göründüklerini algıladılar
fakat günün birinde başka biri biraz
cesaretini topladı o
dahil toplumun içerisinden korkak
toplumun içerisinden yaşadıkları o köhne
mağaranın içerisinden o taşa topa sıkım
Sıkıya bağlandıkları yerden başını
kaldırdı ve gökyüzüne baktı gökyüzüne
baktığında ilginç bir şeyler gördü o
çadırın delikleri dedi yıldız şeklinde
görünen yapıların sabit kalmadığını
hareketli olduğunu gördü ve anladı ki
kendisi merkezde duruyor o gökyüzünde
gördüğü çadır deliklerin hepsi aynı yöne
Aynı hızla hareket ediyordu anlam
veremedi sonra düşündük ki galiba dedi
ben dedi ortada duruyorum
her şey ve her ne varsa benim etrafımda
dolanıyor dedi
Tamam biraz daha geçti biraz daha geçti
ve öyle bir an geldi ki Ya evet Her şey
bizim etrafımızda dolanıyor ama bir
tuhaf dolanıyor dedi Onlar keşfettiler
ki aslında merkezde kendileri değil
güneş var dünya dahil kendilerine dair
Bütün Evren o güneşin etrafında
dolanıyor ve Yıllar Geçti Yıllar geçti
Öyle bir zaman dilimi geldik ki o zaman
birbirini Biz teleskopu icat ettik o
gemici dürbün olarak bildiğiniz o
dürbünlü gökyüzüne çevirdik ve gökyüzüne
baktığımızda yıldızların konumunu
Uzaklığını keşfetmeye başladık biz öyle
küçücük bir cadı sadece küçücük bir
güneş sistemi değil biz dev gibi bir
gezegen yıldız sistemin içerisinde
bulunuyormuşuz adına Samanyolu milkway
dediğimiz bir galaksinin içerisinde
bulunuyormuşuz ve bu yapının içerisinde
trilyonlarca Yıldız varmış ve hepsi
birbiriyle sabit duruyor yerleri hiç
değişmiyor bu inanç öylesine pek işte
öylesine sınavdı ki hiçbir şekilde
aşılamadı bugün yaşadığımız dünyanın
temellerini atan teknolojinin temelini
atan
Einstein bile böyle bir evrene inandı
fakat ondan kısa bir süre sonra
bir kaç yıl sonra Hubble denilen Edwin
Hubble denilen bir adam teleskoptan
baktığında gördüğü cisimlere daha
dikkatli baktığında fark etti ki Evren
Sadece bizim galaksimizden ibaret değil
biz yanlış düşünmüşüz yazdığımız
kitaplar hep yanlışmış bilimin
ilerlediği var olduğunu söylediği işte
sınır bu dedi hiçbir şey gerçek değilmiş
daha da Ötesi varmış Biz onlardan sadece
damlının içerisindeki milyarlarca'nın
içerisinde en küçük damlalardan
biriymişiz evrende yüzlerce milyarlarca
Galaksi varmış ve biz sadece onlardan
biriymişiz izlediğiniz görüntü
2016-2020 yılları arasında geldiğimiz
son noktada evrenin üç boyutlu haritası
ve
çalışmasını bir adım daha ileriye
götürdüğünde ilginç çok daha sıkıntılı
bir konuyu fark etti bu galaksiler
yerinde sabit durmuyor galaksilerde
birbirinden ilerliyor birbirinden
uzaklaşıyor ve birbirlerinden
kaçarcasına uzaklaşıyor İyi de Evren
niye böyle davranıyor niye bunlar sabit
durmuyor düşünmeye başladık son 50 yıla
geldik son 50 yıla düşüncelerimiz daha
da derinleşti daha da derinleşti ve öyle
bir an geldi ki
1980'lerden sonra artık İçinde
bulunduğumuz zamanın ve İçinde
bulunduğumuz o mekan dediğimiz kavramın
gerçek yapısını ortaya koyduk günümüzden
13.8 milyar yıl önce başlayan bu seyri
Ben günümüzde uçsuz bucaksız dev bir
Evren haline geldi
Fakat bu yapıyı fark ettinizde
iliklerinizi dondan başka bir şeyle
karşılaştık zamanın başlangıcında her
şeyin başında O sarı renkte gördüğünüz
bildiğiniz matematik bildiğiniz Kimya ne
varsa temel bilimlere ilişkin her şey
tüm yasalar her şey zıt çalışıyordu Biz
bunu anlayamadık
2000 yıl 2000'li yıllardan sonra dedik
ki hocam bu işte bir iş var Biz bir
şeyleri yanlış yapıyoruz bunu anlamamız
lazım ardı ardına 3 tane uzay aracı
geliştirdik 3 tane teleskopu uzaya
yönlendirdik tüm uzaya taradık tüm uzayı
taradığımızda plankuydu Salatada verilen
bu sonuncu uydunun yaptığı gözlemlerde
evrenin tüm haritasını çıkardık O bizden
uzaklaşan galaksilerin haritasını
çıkardık ekranda gördüğünüz mor renkli
bölgedeki bu üç boyutlu bir uzayın iki
boyutlu düzleme aktarılmışı Hani küresel
haldeki dünya atmasının iki boyutlu
düzleme dönüştürülmüş hali gibi
düşünebilirsiniz o mor renkte bulunan
galaksiler yani şu yöndeki galaksiler
dünyadan müthiş bir hızla uzaklaşıyor
ama sarı bölgedeki galaksiler yani şu
yöndeki galaksiler onlar da dünyadan
uzaklaşıyor ama mor renktekilere göre Bu
yöndekiler çok daha büyük hızlarda
uzaklaşıyor İyi de Evren dediğimiz şey o
ne diyor belirsiz şeyin genişlemesi ile
başlamıştı geniş de veya başlamıştı ve
bir boşluğun içinde genişliyordu o doğal
olarak homojen ve mükemmel bir
simetreyle genişlemesini bekliyorduk ama
bugün baktığımızda bu yöne genişliyor
Ama bu yana uçarcısınız da genişliyor
iyiden ne olabilir acaba bu yönde
gitmemize engel olan bir şey yok da bu
yönde bir şey bizi baskılıyor dışarıda
bakın bir yıldızdan bir gezegenden O
minicik Can fanuslarımızdan beynimizin
anca Algıladığı bir fanuslar söz
etmiyorum tüm evrenden tüm zamandan
bahsediyorum Hani
olaya ilahi boyuttan bahsediyorum size
Bakın bu yönde gitmemizi engelleyen bir
şey var Biz oturduk bilgisayar başına
modellemeye başladık gözlem derilerini
sonra bunu biraz daha detaylı hale
getirdik sonra bir fark ettik ki orada
gördüğünüz beyaz elipse göndererek
gösterilen bölgede evrenin bir balon
gibi düşünün balona şişirdiğinizde nasıl
homojen bir şekilde
genişler ya Evren o şekilde genişleme
isteğinde Hani bazen bir arkadaşınız
balonu şişirirse Siz Espri olsun diye
şişen balona böyle parmağınızı
sokarsanız parmağınızı soktuğunuz yerden
balon içeriye doğru geçer ya
Sanki bizim evrenimizde de o Güney
kısımda beyaz dairenin elektron olduğu
yerde evrenimizin dışında bir güç
parmağını sokmuş Bütün Evren genişlemeye
devam ederken o yönden Evren içe doğru
göçüyor
Tanrım bu nasıl bir şey nasıl bir büyük
yapıdır Bu
başlangıçta anlayamadık sonra ufkumuz
açılmaya başladı
İyi de dedik acaba Sadece bizim
evrenimiz mi var
başka bir evrende olabilir mi ortada
parlak gördüğünüzde böyle bir lale gibi
açılan yer kendi evrenimiz ise hemen her
yöne eşit hız ve simetrede dağılırken
farklı noktadaki bir başka Evren bize
tamponlıyor başka bir Evren olduğunu
fark ettik Hatta ve hatta başka başka
Evrenler
çoklu Evren sadece
Einstein hata yapmamış Bizlerde hata
yapmışız sadece kendi evrenimiz Sadece
kırmızı alanımız yokmuş sahnede bizim
halımızın dışında başka başka halılar da
varmış
ama başka bir şey daha dikkatimizi çekti
kendi evrenimizin oluştuğu noktada
aşağıya yönünde bir Yankı var
simetri var mükemmel bir simetri
bunun ne olduğunu baştan anlayamadık ama
sanki yukarıya doğru böyle Koza şeklinde
açılan bir şeyin tam simetrik Koza
şeklinde alta doğru açılan bir hali var
orada gördüğünüz Yukarısı aşağısı
dediğiniz kavram zaman bir yere
İlerleyen bir zamanla farklı bir yöne
ilerleyen zamanı görüyorsunuz
birbirinden zıt yöne giden Aynı hızla
giden iki zaman ve konumsal mekansal
olarak her şey birebir aynı şekilde
ilerliyor fakat zaman zıt yönü ilerliyor
biz bunları bu noktada bıraktıktan sonra
kendi kırmızı halımızın içerisinde kendi
evlerimizin içerisinde o arada
gördüğünüz minik minik benekli
yıldızların yapısını anlamaya başladık
anlamaya çalıştık ve günü geldiğinde bu
yıldızların bazılarının müthiş oranda
patladığını birbirinden müthiş bir
şekilde etkilendiklerini gördük öyle şey
Öyle hızlı Öyle şiddetli patlıyorlardı
ki gökyüzünde gördüğümüz parlayan
yıldızlar birer kara delik haline
geliyordu ve kara delik dediğimiz şey
öylesine müthiş kütle çekimine sahip ki
etrafında bulunan bütün uzayı
etkileyebiliyor bütün uzaya şekil
verebiliyor o kadar güçlü o kadar
şiddetli kütle çekimine sahiptir Peki o
bütün güçlü çektiğimde sahip cisim nasıl
büyüklükte Acaba ne büyüklükte diye
baktığınızda atomu biliyorsunuz minicik
yok denilecek kadar küçüklükte bir
zerrecek kara delik dediğimiz o devasal
evrenin şekillendiren kütle çekimine
sahip gök cismi ise bir atomun milyar
çarpı milyar çarpı milyarda biri
kadarlık bir hacmin içine yani plank
boyutuna sığabilecek kadar küçük biz bu
yapıyı anlamaya çalışırken dikkatimizi
farklı farklı şeyler çekmeye başladı
mesela Acaba bir yıldızdan ne büyüklükte
ne güçlü kara delik oluşuyor diye biz
formüller yazmaya başladık formüller
geliştirmeye başladık Ve bugün
ulaştığımız en detaylı formül Bu
basitleştirilmiş bir halde ne olduğuna
bakmayın Sadece şunu söyleyeyim size
formülde en gördüğünüz yere bir
cisminsel ben
kütle mi oraya yazarsanız beni bir kara
delik yapmak istediğinizde ne olana
kadar sıkıştırmanız gerektiğini söyleyen
bir formül bu Eğer en kütleli bir cismi
80 kilogramlık bir insanı kara delik
yapmak istiyorsanız hangi hacmin
içerisine sıkıştırmanız gerekiyor Onun
yarıçapını veriyor ve biz biraz
aykırıyız biliyorsunuz uzay bilimlerinde
Az sonra bir de gözlenebilen dediğimiz
şu bütün evreni düşündük ki acaba tek
bir kara delik yapabilir miyiz
gözlenebilen Evren dediğimiz o
gözleyebildiğimiz bütün varlık aleminin
bulunduğu bu evrenin bütün kütlesini
hesapladık her ne varsa Az önce sabah
oturumunda hocaların bahsettiği bir
karanlık madde var Onu da dahil O da
dahil hepsini hesapladık hepsinin
hesapladık Bir de evrenin bugünkü
yarıçapını ölçtük küresel bir şekilde
kabul edip çapını ölçtüğümüzde
13.8 milyar Işık yılında uçsuz bucaksız
bir evrende çok büyük kütleli bir yapı
olduğunu fark ettik dedik ki biz bu
evrenin içerisindeki bütün madde bütün
gözlenebilir gözlenemeyen enerji her ne
varsa hepsini öyle bir sıkıştıralım ki
tek bir kara delik elde edelim bütün
kütleye Az önce gördüğünüz formülüne
koyduğumuzda
reyting olarak bize evrenin sıkışması
gereken yere çapanı
13.8 milyar ışık yılı olarak verdi
bir dakika ya eğer bütün
gözleyebildiğimiz evreni kara delik
yapmak için
13.8 milyar Işık yılına sıkıştırmamız
gerekiyorsa Bütün Evren O zaman tek bir
kara delik olacaksa
İyi de Evren zaten uç nokta 8 milyar
yarıçapın içerisinde çapının içerisinde
Ne yani benim Evren dediğim şey zaten
başlı başına bir kara delik mi
İyi de kara delik dediğimiz şey hani tek
bir atomun milyar çarpı milyar x
milyarda biri kadarlık bir alandaydı
benim bedenimde trilyonlarca atom var
Sen ne diyorsun burada bir saçmalık yok
mu bakın sadece benim bedenimde
milyarlarca katrilyonlarca atom var
siz biz
gezegenimiz güneş sistemi galaksimiz
bütün evrendeki galaksilerin tamamı yine
bir kardelenin içinde görünüyor ve o
kara deliğin boyutu Biraz onun
milyar çarpı milyar çarpı milyarda biri
kadarlık bir alanda bulunuyor
Allah'ım kafayı yiyeceğim
Bu astrofizikçiler bir yerden sonra
hocam şartları indiriyorlar O noktaya
geldik biz dedik Biz sıkıntı var burada
Bir de kendi evrenimizin oluşmasına
baktığımızda böyle iki birbirinden biri
yukarıya doğru giden biri aşağıya doğru
Yankı şeklinde giden bir yapıdaydı biz
bunu bu şekilde çizdiğimizde bu şekil
bana tanıdık bir şey geliyor
Albert söylemişti bunu Albert Einstein
söylemişti Roza Einstein Köprüsü
dediğimiz sizin solucan deliği olarak
bildiğiniz bir yerden bir yere bir
Mekandan bir mekana bir zamandan bir
zamana gittiniz solucan deliğine
benzeyen bir yapı var
günümüz astron fiziği İçinde
bulunduğumuz Alem dediğimiz Varlık ve
zaman aleminin diğer kara deliğin
içerisinde sıkışık halde biraz solucan
deliğinin içerisinde sadece zaman
ekseninde parçalanmak üzere olduğunu
gösteriyor
bu muazzam bir bulgu Bu bize bazı
şeyleri yok olduğunu söylüyor Nedir o
yok olanlar o yok olanlar Sizsiniz
benim bu dünya bu alem Aslında yok
Biz 2018'e geldiğimizde
kuantum fizikçilerine dedik ki; sizin
Albert einsteina
geçmiyor gelin beraber çözelim dedik son
slaytım size göstereceğim bu ekrandaki
oturduk tüm dünyada kuantum fizikçileri
astron fizikçiler kozmoloji alanında
çalışanlar evrenin yapısını çözmeye
çalıştık ve sicim koyamı ve en koyamı
olarak 2 tane Kuantum fiziğine rakip
kuam oluşturduk ve bu kuramlar İçinde
bulunduğumuz Varlık ve zaman aleminin
aslında
bizim
için dediğimiz gördüğümüz algıladığımız
üç boyutlu zaman ekonomi dediğimiz Evren
dediğimiz bir şeyin yüksekliği genişliği
ve uzunluğu olarak tanımladığımız o üç
boyutlu evrenin Aslında Burada
gördüğünüz perde gibi 11 boyutlu bir
yapının içerisinde sadece 3 boyutlu
olduğunu gösteriyor
kafamız daha da karıştı hocam ama bir
problem var
günümüzden 20-30 bin yıl önceki İlke
insan dediğim Cahil insan dediğim korkak
insan dedim adam da kendi evrenini
içinde yaşadığı çadırın delikleri olarak
algılıyordu oradan sızan delikler olarak
algılanıyordu ve bugün milyarlarca dolar
harcayarak anlamaya çalıştığımız evrenin
de ona benzeyen bir yapı olduğunu
bulmaya başladık biz astronomi
astrofizik ve bilim tarihinde kendi
bulduğumuz doğruların bile yanlış
olduğunu yine kendimiz bulduk Dün
söylediğim şeyin bugün hatalı olduğunu
biliyorum Belki bugün size
anlattıklarımda yarın biri çıkacak o
Hasan hocanın size anlattıkları Külliyen
hatalıydı Hocam fanusunu hala çözememiş
diyecek Siz siz olun Okuduğunuz
kitaplara da sorgulamayı unutmayın ve
gerçeği o zaman bulacaksınız size
gösterdiğimiz formüller size
anlattığımız matematik size anlattığımız
fizik ve kimyada bir yerde çöküp kalacak
Çünkü İçinde bulunduğumuz Evren Sadece
bu kitaplarda yetmiyor görmemiz
gözlemlememiz lazım paralel evrenleri ve
çoklu Evren modelini gördüğümüzde
yaklaşık 200 bin 250 bini bulan
astrofizikçi sayısına baktığımızda
dünyada en az
%95'i Olmaz Böyle Şey saçmalık dedi Ve
bugün uydular dahil her şey
laboratuvardaki deneyler daireler çok da
evrenleri ve paralel evrenleri
gösteriyor ve biz kendi kendimize
tartışı ve kendi kendimizin fanuslarını
kırma aşamasına geldik Siz daha bugünden
kırmak için çabalayın Dilediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ediyorum